thank you very much Hannah and welcome
everybody
when Hannah asked me some months ago to
chair this event
I thought crikey do I understand what it
is and I spent the last few months
because Hannah asked me a while ago to
do this sort of talking to friends who
are not stupid about what is blotching
and you get such a wide selection of
views about what precisely blockchain is
that it needs a lot of people to wonder
is blockchain anything and it sort of
goes from the prosaic a set of records
kept across boundaries with a network of
ways of controlling the information via
code on that network so it is immutable
and trusted by anyone who uses that
network to frankly the revolutionary
this can change the way we live even
more than maybe people thought the
internet could in the early 1990s so
there's a vast array of differences
about opinion a difference of opinion
about what this actually means and to
navigate ourselves around this
complicated maze of blockchain are four
particularly brilliant experts I always
worry that when the media start talking
about technology the mainstream media
that's the moment at which that basic
new technology is over because if we get
it it's not interesting so I hope that
the people on the panel here will be
able to help us through some of the
complexities of these issues it's when I
get a little mood feel for from the
audience hannah laid out the question
quantum leap forward or digital
snake-oil who here is in the
item leap forward camp and the Pelican
boat
okay fits lightly and who is in the
digital snake or a lot of techno people
basically showing off about something
that ever you know about okay okay quite
quite balance bending towards the
positive so let's see if I have four
fantastic experts can help us oh and
actually there's one thing as well
Bitcoin isn't blockchain I suppose is
one thing that were saying at the
beginning it's on blockchain but it
isn't it and I think a lot of the public
sort of maybe confuse those two things
who in here has got a little bit of
cryptocurrency okay some early adopters
here who've lost a lot of value but
depending when they depending on when
they bought it depending on when they
bought it excellent so I was trying to
get this explanation what's this idea
this explanation really important
now Jamie barley on my far left tweeted
very wickedly as some weeks ago a little
explanation and he answered this
question can you give a very simple
description of blockchain for
non-specialists is that Jamie answered
this question sure it's cryptographic
Lee supported immutable decentralized
database system that creates webs of
trust through relationships while
pushing self sovereignty to the edge of
the network that wasn't ironic I know
you would be clear about that
you were being funny so we'll see how
well Jamie does this panel so let's
start with um Primavera de filippi
lawyer she asked me to say crypto lawyer
at the beginning bunny I mean that you
sort of disappear or something old and
really be here but um she's a lawyer
expert on legal challenges the
opportunities of blockchain is there a
way to make them into new models of
governments participate Reedus in making
that more revolutionary edge
of what lock chain may be she's
permanent researcher at the National
Center of scientific research in Paris
and faculty associate at the Berkman
Kline Center for Internet and Society at
Harvard University also also the author
of blockchain and the law
welcome to the right where I say this
president vit as you are he's the
founder and first elected president of
the Free Republic of liberland
who-knows-where liberland is look at all
these early adopters here this is too
many trendies in the room too many
trendies in the room yes it's located
within Croatia and Serbia on the west
bank of the Danube country which aims to
be the first to bathe its government
structures on blockchain technology and
be the freest jurisdiction on the planet
founding member of the Czech libertarian
free citizens party Jamie Bartlett on my
far left author maybe crypto author I
don't know I have one of his books here
which I do hardly recommend radicals
which has a bit of libel and stuff in
there and a lot about blockchain a lot
about new ways of of thinking around
these issues so author expert in the
notion of a social influence of the
Internet how it changes the way we
operate with each other cryptocurrency
surveillance technology machine learning
Big Data all those things basically 99%
of us have not a sodding idea what it
means but we know it's very very
important director of the center for the
analysis of social media which is a
collaborative piece of work between
demos the think-tank
and the University of Sussex his books
beyond radicals include the darknet the
people and most recently the people
versus tech how the internet is killing
democracy and how we can save it
optimistic Jamie good to hear David
Gerard is sort of the IT guy so you know
if anything goes wrong he can sort of
turn it on and turn it off again he's
been an information technology for 20
years as a systems administrator
award-winning music journalist which is
an enormous ly impressive thing and a
bit of a blockchain skeptic if we're
absol
honesty works he offers the news blog on
Bitcoin and is author of the book attack
of the 50-foot blockchain Bitcoin
blockchain aetherium and smart contracts
which are all different things I now
discover described by the New York Times
as a sober as he looks his evening in
his suit and black tie
riposte to all the upbeat forecasts
about cryptocurrency so they be sort of
the Undertaker of the evening he will be
whenever things get too excitable he
will bring us back to earth and stickers
in a coffin so let's just briefly go
around the Palace get a bit of a tone
about where they are in this debate
president vid mr. Vitti's at mr. video
cables alright just maybe if it would do
just give us two sentences blockchain
you you sort of put your hand up about
quantum leap forward why'd you say that
the biggest thing about it is removing
the third party and when we are talking
about third party we're talking about
things like central banks like
insurances like banks regular banks like
governments ultimately and it's a really
big thing you know I'm just saying it
like nothing really big is happening but
it's a really big thing ultimately we
will not need these institutions in the
future because the third trusted party
actually doesn't have to be there
anymore
so all the things that provide security
around the world forget oh not not all
of them but a lot of them like I think
the next big revolution that is
happening because of blockchain will be
the decentralized insurance companies
and there are a couple startups already
pushing that I think it will need like
two or three more years but we will see
that out of these huge institutions that
have these huge buildings and a lot of
bureaucrats in there we will actually
see a completely decentralized system of
insuring yourself which much cheaper and
much more efficient way everything on
blockchain without any big building
necessary based on reputation and under
centralized systems and can you imagine
how much how much energy does that
actually release from the
system into the society right and the
same thing will apply with the
government's Primavera quantum leap
forward digital snake or you sort of
half put your hand up towards the snake
or side so it would not be a fellow
traveler you know I actually I wanted to
raise my hand to God of them I'm taking
a quantum answer I'm actually but
convinced that it has wonderful
opportunity and it has actually a
beautiful quantum leap and at the same
time so it's not in the middle I'm
actually but that they've got extreme at
the same time it's potentially being
used as a wonderful type of digital
snake all right so it just it's a very
baby see you sort of both sides of the
fence as my position actually this I've
agreed to that so it has both positives
but also the negative potential in terms
of the centralization in terms of
disintermediation transparency
accountability so it can actually create
new structures of modify the internal
structure of existing institution which
I think can have a very important impact
at the same time those same potentiality
can also be used or abused to some
extent in order to actually you know
sell miracles and this is a little bit
what is happening today and tonight to
my view tease these kind of these kind
of like you know especially in the kind
of the ice you are like this kind of
selling things just because you say
blockchain and is gonna solve everything
is to some extent fading like sitting
shades on top of the actual real
opportunities that perhaps have not yet
been explored enough to acquire the
visibility that they could so Jamie the
snake old sales people have jumped on
what could be a clever technology do you
agree with that or do you actually think
the technology itself offers a huge
amount at once once described in a piece
I read before this is trying to use the
Hubble Space Telescope to look across
the road yeah I mean this this this week
I received an email from a blockchain
start-up saying they were using a
blockchain to beat obesity have no idea
how
but that is a good example of the way in
which there's an awful lot of snake oil
sales people out there an awful lot but
that doesn't mean that it isn't
potentially very revolutionary not maybe
in the next two to three to five years
but beyond that I think that the
prospect of large-scale adoption of
decentralized networks in immutable
databases impossible to censor bits of
the Internet
is going to be quite revolutionary but
that doesn't mean that it's good quantum
leap forward sounds obviously good the
quantum leap forward that we're going to
get with this is actually going to cause
us a lot of problems we'll build on some
of that Jamie a little later David are
you of similar opinion what are your
what are your main concerns about is
there a tulip fever elements to
blockchain which should worry us I think
you couldn't say there wasn't really
looking at the last year like the
blockchain data structure is 40 years
old it's pretty good data structure it's
pretty cool
the Merkel tree data structure it is not
new but it is being marketed with a
bunch of outlandish miracle promises and
the implication you'll get all of these
promises all at the same time and never
mind actual technical limitations or
anything and all the promises that the
things branded blockchain are sold with
are actually old Bitcoin promises
recycled most of which Bitcoin had
basically failed by 2014 like bitcoin is
not decentralized anymore it's like got
three major miners and one company makes
80 percent of all the mining chips it
doesn't scale up that sort of thing it's
immutable which means that there's a
bunch of illegal pornography on the
blockchain nobody can ever remove so
that's a great win but the thing is the
promises were then moved into things
branded blockchain now there's no
definition of what a blockchain is
legally because actually it's a simple
40 year old data structure with a
certain amount of marketing attached
I've seen all sorts of things sold as
blockchain some of which drop on a
sliding scale from a full
coin cryptocurrency decentralized to
literally just the data structure like
the famous if you've heard about Estonia
is great blockchain revolution that's a
thing called ksi guard time which they
renamed ksi blockchain in 2012 to sell
it and the marketing worked amazing luck
I didn't say they're wrong but you know
it's literally just a time-stamped
ledger and so yourself someone's selling
you blockchain they are literally the
hype is the actual product and the date
and the actual program comes later so
there is no technical tech there is no
solid technological agreed definition of
a blockchain except something that
attracts dreams and hopes which might
not be a bad thing so an old technology
in a new rapper Primavera help us here
with what it is now you're going to talk
us through hopefully in relatively
simple terms for me if no one else
precisely what it is that we are
attempting to talk about kick us off
with slides oh yes just make sure it's
super simple but so basically the
easiest way to explain the
functionalities of the blockchain is by
analogy with the Internet so the
Internet has enabled us to communicate
on a peer-to-peer basis bypassing many
of the traditional intermediaries like
TV broadcaster and radio channel and it
also has enabled the emergence of those
peer-to-peer file-sharing networks which
makes it possible for people to exchange
information directly with one another
and then of course this is very
important and very useful whenever it is
about exchanging information of
knowledge but it can actually be quite
problematic when it comes to exchanging
money of any other kind of hot sauce
which is innocently scarce and so this
is why when we actually want to transfer
money over the Internet
we generally rely on this kind of
centralized financial institutions like
banks of PayPal's
which are responsible to verify every
transaction in order to make sure that
no one can spend more money than what
they actually have the problem with this
system is that this obviously
reintroduce one layer of centralization
over the internet and the system only
works so long as we can't ask those
operators and so what if instead of
delegating those tasks to the
centralized potatoes we could create
instead a decentralized payment system
and the system as it exists it's Bitcoin
so Midtown is a virtual currency that
can be traded on a peer-to-peer network
without the need to rely on any
centralized operator or financial
institution and so Bitcoin was created
in 2008 by absurd animals entity called
Satoshi Nakamoto and as opposed to
traditional fiat currencies like the
gyros of the pounds which are issued by
central banks and controlled by estates
the issuance of Bitcoin is defined by a
computer protocol which precisely
stipulate the total amount of bitcoins
that will ever be created 21 million and
the speed at which those bitcoins will
be generated so today it is 12.5
bitcoins every 10 minutes more or less
and so we can see how it can't somehow
replicates our simulates the
characteristic of gold Gold cannot be
created out of nothing
it must be extracted from the ground and
then as time passes and the reserve of
gold gets depleted then the harder it
becomes to find new gold and in the same
way bitcoins cannot be created out of
nothing new bitcoins are generated every
time a computer identified the solution
to a mathematical problem whose
difficulty increases with the network
size so this means that the math people
are contributing the home computing
resources to the network the new harder
it actually becomes to generate new
bitcoins and so this mathematical
problem is actually similar to the
problem of finding the solution to a
padlock so one needs to try every single
possibility in order to find the right
combination but once the solution has
been found it's very easy for
one else to verify that it is the
correct solution now of course you might
wonder because it is indeed a virtual
currency then how can we trust the
system how can we be sure that people
are not going to reproduce and multiply
the bitcoins in the same way as they can
reproduce digital content and so the
Bitcoin network operates on top of this
auto technology the blockchain which
makes it possible to exchange value in a
secure and this centralized manner
without the need to rely on any trusted
authority of intermediary operator and
so how does this work
exactly well instead of assigning to
this centralized operator the task of
verifying every transactions with
Bitcoin the history of all transactions
is stored on this common database the
blockchain and this database is shared
among all the network participants who
are all contributing to the verification
and to the validation of those
transactions and because everybody holds
a copy of the blockchain it is virtually
impossible to chip because if one tries
to modify even a single one of those
transactions the fraud will be
immediately detected by all the network
participants and then once those
transactions has been validated they are
stored in a chronological order inside a
block of transactions which incorporate
a reference to the previous blocks and
this reference is part of the same
mathematical problem which I have
described before and this means that the
only way to validate transactions on the
Bitcoin blockchain is to find the right
combination that will enable the system
to attach a new block of transaction to
the previous chain of blocks and so the
blockchain is after all just this long
chain of transactions which reference
each other and the longer is the chain
then the higher is the security of the
network because the modification of a
single one of those transactions will
invalidate the reference to the previous
blocks which will inevitably break the
chain here is my little introduction of
finally understood every word about
there comes you down is the is the issue
given that the data might be hold or
sorry the the the structures might be
quite old it's the issue with do you
agree with David the issue with
blockchain is not what it is which is
the defense relies ledger used digitally
but the use the marketing that lay is
laid above it is that the issue that it
is being sold in ways that aren't really
blockchain all at all revolutionary well
actually I will disagree about the fact
that the technology is old in the sense
that the blockchain is based on a set of
existing technologies which are quite
old but the combination of all those
technologies together is actually quite
new it was created it was created with
the invention of Bitcoin in 2008 and the
particularity of this is that the
blockchain for the first time managed to
actually resolve one of the fundamental
problems that will not have been
resolved until now except by relying on
a centralized operator which is the
question of double spending right so if
I have a centralized operator and every
every transaction needs to go through
this operator in order to know whether
it's valid or not then it's quite easy
to to avoid any kind of double spanning
one if I have ten pounds and then I
transfer ten pounds here and 10 pounds -
then the centralized Authority would
just accept the format and reject the
second if you are in a different forum
it's really difficult to actually
resolve the problem and the the the
radical innovation of Bitcoin is
actually that it provided a mechanism by
which if I sent ten pounds here and ten
pound staff then there is this form of
consensus making that will actually
decide event of the earth but valid
independently they are but valid so you
cannot just say design is correct design
is incorrect and because the network
doesn't have a common time according to
which one I actually have emitted false
then you need this kind of consensus
mechanism that will actually dictate
whether this one is considered valid of
this one is considered valid and does it
become
via that system a way of
disintermediation or does it need a
checking mechanism beyond that if that
trust breaks down if that consensus is
somehow broken is there any need for
lawyers I mean in in the context of
Bitcoin the consensus is basically what
dictates the validity of a transaction
right so well first they need to be
mathematically valid and then you need
to decide which one will actually go now
of course the the system itself is
subject to a particular type of
constraint which you know one should
actually have control over more than 50%
of the computing power in the network
otherwise you can actually to some
extent double span you can you can crop
the network in validating transaction
and then mining on the other side much
faster in order to validate also a lot
of transactions so as long as you stay
under the 50% threshold then at least
until now it has proved to work now the
problem is is a different problem the
problem is what if I make a transaction
and this transaction was not meant to
you but to someone else then usually I
will be able to go to my bank and
without that transaction whereas here I
cannot because once it's done once it
has been validated no one has actually
the capacity to revert it same thing if
someone is stealing my bitcoins right so
if someone is acquiring a particular
digital asset in a way that is actually
illegitimate in the real world I will be
just the cloud to be the illegitimate
owner of this this asset and then people
can take it away on seize it and with a
court order whereas in the case of
Bitcoin even regardless of what the law
says if I have transacted my beacon to
someone else then no one can actually
come and intervene to actually take this
property back fit you started off just a
couple of sentences about this notion of
takes out the mediators the the central
bank's the bank's
Huber's the whoever it might be who get
between the service I want and me gives
them your overview of how you view the
revolutionary aspects of what blockchain
gives us and the notion that this is as
fundamental as a as a new way of
governance I've got a great example and
I will do a small page here for
Primavera
they're working there are two major
projects now in development one of them
is Dow stack and the other one is Eragon
if you want to check it out and they're
both for incorporating companies on
etherium and it's a great thing right
right now you can basically incorporate
your company of course you can do it in
liberal amber you can also do it in
other one of these platforms and you
just don't get a incorporation paper you
get the whole system of governance that
is immutable
you've got the shares you've got the
decision making rights you name it
you know you've got the whole company
and you don't need any more lawyers
because all the systems that are usually
written somewhere in paper
hidden in some you know storage and
people just kind of trust each other
that those shares belong to there and
this decision right everything is now
written on aetherium
and it's such a great thing that now you
know these private institutions
basically offer much better
incorporation then any other nation
stage could because it not just comes
with a single list in some registry but
they are giving you the whole company as
a system which doesn't need lawyers
anymore because all the rules within the
company and with the money management
are written in a code which is immutable
and running on top of a theorem and it's
one of those great things which I think
etherium like tangibly is bringing us or
smart contracts in general but what
about the point that if a mistake is
made or I want to retract or someone
breaks into it someone starts stealing
whatever it is my product on blockchain
where is the Court of Appeal oh this is
actually let me pitch for labor land a
little bit that's where a liberal and
comes in and now in our jurisdiction
everybody basically has
married account that means how much they
have contributed to the society that
they are living in and the more taxes
you pay the more merits you have the
higher is your vote but in our system of
the centralized justice that we are
planning together with plurals that I
owe you can actually buy the system of
the centralized jurors you can take
people's merits away so ok it's possible
that I steal your bitcoins you know i
hack into your computer but if you can
prove it in a system of liberal and
decentralized justice we just put on the
phone on my account liability in the
same value as of the stolen bitcoins so
there would be always list of criminals
and by the way it's growing also every
day with liberland there are some little
criminals in Lebanon yes so people that
have acquired - merits for whatever they
have done usually some sort of robbery
besides what merits right right now it's
kind of centralized but the main I'm not
the president the president made the
second China make sure we actually have
a facility for awhile that we're gonna
move on well you know like you know
monarchies have been around here around
around the world for quite some time and
they work well let me remind you that
like to entertain was also a monarchy
with kind of dictatorial powers and it
is the richest state on this planet so
but of course there is a problem with
governance when the monarch gets crazy
it doesn't work anymore or you know just
the son doesn't really want to follow
his father's footsteps so what we are
doing in liberal and we want to put
everything on blockchain so the whole
governance is on blockchain maybe used
similar platform agnostic but we want to
put a platform on top of it the
decentralized system of jurors randomly
selected from people that will be able
to basically balance of all these
criminal acts through a system of merits
and and how did you is it just use a you
and a group of people decide on these
merits and then the method for which
that will be tested well no the sister
are there Aria the idea for it is that
really qualified citizens from all the
citizens that apply to be basically
jurors will be randomly selected and the
first round three randomly selected
people qualified jurors from the nation
will be so
for any case actually the first round is
a mediator if you don't buy a mediation
the Bupa parties don't agree about
solution of the dispute and there is
three jurors and in another round if one
of the parties appeals there will be six
years and in another round if one party
appeals there be 12 jurors and we want
to also include some sort of Dubai
financial district ultimate resolution
system but it's very costly we would
like to solve most of the disputes
within liberland through our system of
merits and again I would like to get rid
of this obligation as soon as possible
and and I know that that is something
that will really kick off the whole
project so people will pay tax in all
they do because it's a voluntary tax if
you want to acquire more merits
basically more shares of liberland you
have to basically exchange your whatever
currency for merits fining Jamie Jamie
you've been you've been to Vic
conferences you get to see them you've
engaged with it with not a bit but many
others in liberland is there a
revolutionary aspect which is a
reasonable one - what blockchain can do
around governance yeah I mean I think
it's very exciting what it's doing and I
really enjoyed going over there and
visiting it and but I don't think it's
quite there yet
I want some good reasons why
decentralized I mean the way I think
about it simply is decentralized in
mutable databases that cannot be sort of
historical records that cannot be
tampered or changed so we're talking
about the end of censorship which is
very good if you think government
censorship or government controlling
information is a bad idea and it's quite
open about this or both his own
libertarian instincts and the origins of
Bitcoin itself you know from a quite
hardline crypto anarchist community who
just do not like government's very much
I can see some great uses I can see how
especially in countries where voting
ballots are stuffed routinely if you can
create some kind of decentralized system
for people to check that their own votes
have been counted accurately that's
great but why are we so down on
intermediaries
intermediaries are necessary when things
go wrong and things nearly always go
wrong code goes wrong vit mentioned the
Dow a new a new way of investing money
into a into a sort of decentralized
company well we had a dowel ready and
that went rather badly wrong because
thousands of people invested an awful
lot of money into it but they'd been a
flaw in the code allowing somebody to
get in and funnel out loads of the
etherium that was in there and no one
could do anything about it
it was unstoppable because no one was in
charge and David mentioned the
possibility in the future of illegal
material appearing on the blockchain but
also we have this gdpr about your right
to be forgotten to remove data
impossible in a world of blockchain so
these things I think had really
undermined people's confidence in the
way we do government that no court or
police or jury or judge in the world can
remove stuff that shouldn't be there and
that is a pretty fundamental change what
was interesting about the DAO issue and
the the hack was the point that
supporters of Dow made about that was
was well yes it was like it's like
stealing the Mona Lisa yet you've stolen
something but it is immediately
traceable and therefore not sellable and
so there's nothing that can be done with
the data that was hacked is that is that
a reasonable point that because of this
traceability issue that things yes
cracking takes on a different meaning
when everything is absolutely traceable
it's it's it's it that is true to some
extent but with a lot of the other
crypto currencies for example stolen
Bitcoin do not get returned what happens
is they get filtered to another
cryptocurrency then another one then
back to Bitcoin and then cashed out in
real money and something similar like
that happened to me which is why I'm
here speaking because I lost all my
Bitcoin
Jamiel share your paper please that's my
family the intelligence squared family
who all love you Amy we're here for you
yeah tell us your painful I'd rather not
go into the details of it but but a lot
of money no okay so it's not it's a it's
it's not the question of perfectly trace
of traceable transactions is not
completely true but I think the broader
point was that what had to happen with
the Dow was that a group of people who
were running it made the decision to
fork it off and to almost start again
yes and that shows you that you know in
the end people then jump in and take
over so the promises of decentralization
often fall slightly short but I don't
think we're thinking widely enough I
mean if we talk about crypto currencies
rather than just the blockchain the
prospect that governments are not going
to be able to easily raise taxes you
know more than anyone about this problem
especially in the coming years with all
the problems we're facing is dramatic
every most big revolutions have started
in the past in our democracies over
whether tax should be raised and how to
raise that legitimately government is
not going to sit by and let tax raising
power disappear because everyone's using
crypto currencies that are hard to trace
what will happen governments will take
them over and they'll run them and then
we'll have government run block chains
where everybody's transactions are
monitored because it's all been
centralized by government and then the
kind of the libertarian dream the
exciting dream turns into a bit of a
nightmare and it becomes a perfect sort
of surveillance system isn't that you're
worried think that you create these
systems which you say can be trusted and
ultimately as Jamie says governments
have a vested interest and an and and an
interest that has been granted them by
US citizens to come and say that that
system doesn't work for everybody so
therefore we're going to take it over
for whatever reason it might be now if
you're in China will be certain reasons
if your America with different reasons
and if you're in Germany it'll be other
reasons but in the end however much you
do with blockchain if it starts
the very structure of of let's at least
say democratic government based as Jamie
says on tax the government is going to
respond the cool thing about these
things is that the more you attack them
the more they grow because it's
impossible to take it down there is this
famous CIA paper about you know how do
we take down Bitcoin we don't like it
and the resolution is no we cannot take
down Bitcoin and the same thing I think
I would argue a little bit there that
you know the Monaro is one of those
completely anonymous untraceable
cryptocurrencies that will always be a
good alternative to your official
governmental blockchain that you will
have to use it is as hard as taking down
Internet to take these things down which
ultimately will make it okay some
governments might turn off internet
because of that but what it what it will
create ultimately they're just putting
themselves to Dark Age instead of
embracing evolution they're they're
fighting against it David it is too
negative
you've heard the the glories of what
what could happen the notion of trusted
groups people coming together to produce
trusted networks in a way that allows
what would once have only been localized
face-to-face allows you to do that
across nations across the world in
larger groups and that's trusting your
fellow person
down the digital road so to speak is
better than vesting powers in central
governments in central banks in systems
that the public simply cannot see and
certainly have no way of controlling
isn't that the reaction in the public
against so much of what is going on now
they cannot see and they cannot control
what is going on well at this point you
have to differentiate between the
promise and the realities because anyone
can make a really really good pitch
saying we will free you from the your
oppressors but what a system have you
got in their place because and a lot of
this talk about how bitcoin will
overthrow governments is fairy stories
the bitcoiners tell themselves
governments don't act like
when Bitcoin 0.1 was released in 2009
there was a message on the mailing was
saying huh no government could stand for
this they'll come down on this
immediately and you know that that's
literally not the history of finance in
the last 400 years what happens when
someone comes up with a new financial
instrument is the government says that
looks interesting let's see how you go
by the way regulations apply then
someone makes money then someone else
does something dodgy and they say whoops
sorry that's a Ponzi scheme you know
they actually are there to do those and
stuff like that but it's frankly
delusional thinking that the governments
of capitalist countries have something
against people making money in finance
because they don't you know Bitcoin is
rail against the SEC but their missions
the u.s. regulator their mission
statement the third part of it is
facilitate capital formation here's a
government agency who literally see
their job is helping you make a great
big pile of money you know but the
second part of their mission is maintain
orderly fair and efficient markets and
their first spy last statement is
protect investors what you happen
happens with when people make promise of
a trustless currency is you end up with
people who just can't be trusted this is
what you see over and over in the
cryptocurrency world it is saturated
with the most blatant outrageous crooks
it is as an investment it's junk quality
it's a zero-sum game because there is
not really much of a functional crypto
currency economy like if you have a pile
bitcoins that's not a pile of capital
that you can invest in growth but it is
growing though David the the the the
number of corporations that will accept
crypto currencies as methods of payment
is growing to jump in okay go have a
sliver jump in no the number is not
going he went up for a while through
about 2013-2014 then they discovered
that actually bitcoiners don't spend
their bitcoins it's just not it's not a
very good payment network there is a use
case for it like
this there are other people who take
crypto usually I paid neither because
bitcoins are too light too unmanageable
these days with transaction fees being
seem to be rather higher but some it's
not much of a use case I mean there is
the famous one consumer use case of
Bitcoin which was to buy drugs on the
darknet which drove bitcoins price up
from 2011 onwards up to about 2013 when
that price rise up for the first bubble
was found be pretty much entirely market
manipulation on the mount GOx exchange
there the trouble with an unregulated
area is that people rapidly learn why
financial regulation exists which is
that you have to have some assurance
that even if your market is a cutthroat
dog-eat-dog market you need assurance
the market itself won't screw you over
and you don't have that assurance from
cryptocurrency well you do to an extent
so already already the platform's are
regulated but the currency is not it's
not really a currency is it it's a youth
it's it's it's a commodity Morrisey it's
a commodity it's a money aspect yes so
we the regulations don't actually
regulate the cryptocurrency but they
regulate the markets that deal in crypto
yeah but the thing is the regulators
have only shown up in the last year or
so and that is a problem
like the regulators are slow-moving but
thorough for instance there now
prosecuting a pile of people who engaged
in dodgy behavior in 2013 and 2014 for
example it turns out that if you're
going to commit financial fraud you
probably shouldn't do it on an immutable
ledger that anyone could access forever
you might think that's an obvious point
but they're still busting people off the
Silk Road so if you're going to do
crimes don't do them in the permanent
record and you know this stuff is crimes
when the SEC first was talking about
icos in mid 2017 they said look the
doubt was clearly a security it was
actually broke the law but they tried to
make good so we won't prosecute but
don't do this again
you see finance people when you tell
them they go right we better not do that
again
because they know what regulation is for
is to make give your marketing integrity
so people can trust even trading on the
market crypto people went AHA but what
does word is mean there and they got
really querulous and litt picky about it
as if the law cared about that which it
totally doesn't and it's like only now
they're finally having to actually issue
a denier orders arrest the worst
offenders that sort of thing and you
know ico people I talk to people they
really want to do this right and they're
worried will they bust us I say well no
not if you're honest but there's just so
many dishonest people out there because
when they see an exciting new thing this
attracts starry-eyed naive people who
think this is their ticket to get rich
and it then attracts a whole lot of
scammers to prey upon them so yeah I
mean maybe I expect that in a few years
cryptocurrencies will be a normal
regulated sort of financial instrument
but a whole lot of people are going to
get busted first and because they just
won't be told I Prevert what to David's
point will we get to will we get to a
regulated blockchain system or does that
defeat the point of blotter you said
there'll always be a need for lawyers
can you control it can you regulate it
in some manner which means that some of
the attacks that David is making upon it
is it is a world for criminals basically
to buy to work is there or is there a
way that blockchain can be regulated
which means that some of those concerns
that are raised by David can be
well I'm putting my heart of a lawyer
here yeah um I think anyhow you never
regulate a technology it doesn't mean
anything it's you regulate a particular
use application of the technology and
again what you regulate is first we need
to look at what the applications are and
then you regulate when is derive into
something that is against public health
morality now the challenge is that like
if we actually look at the dinner chef
at of like the early internet days we
could see that there was all these same
very similar negative about with
creating this kind of like completely
decentralized network and like the
Declaration of Independence of the
cyberspace government's not having the
heart nor the capacity to actually exert
the sovereignty over the internet and
then very soon we have noticed that
actually it's not that difficult to
regulate the internet because there is a
bunch of intermediaries and if we
regulate the intermediaries then we can
indirectly regulate the people
interacting on those platforms now the
interesting question with blockchain is
that we actually lose this figure of the
intermediary which is probably the most
efficient means of regulation on the on
the cyberspace and so the question is
does it mean that we are actually you
know actually materializing those early
dreams of crypto anarchy and things like
this well probably not because there is
actually different kinds of
intermediaries alright so you have the
miners you have the developers you have
the validators you have the exchanges
you have like the blockchain Explorer so
there is a bunch of new intermediate of
events just like the commercial
operators so you cannot regulate the
technology and you cannot regulate
Bitcoin and you cannot stop Bitcoin but
what you can do is actually implement
specific regulations saying that no
commercial actor in a particular
jurisdiction can accept Bitcoin you can
require exchanges of whatever operator
is actually dealing with bitcoins to
actually fulfill very extensive amounts
of formalities
so that all the small startups need to
run away and then the only of those
large large institution that you can
actually very easily regulate so the
game nowadays is actually to identify
what are those new avenues without the
new levels the
exist on which you can actually affect
the use of the technology knowing that
you can never actually stop the
technology itself right and so as long
as there is a few people anywhere in the
world running a Bitcoin blockchain node
then these these blocks will be
available to people that manage to so
either you have to shut down the
internet or firewall everything down ah
you will basically just create this kind
of legitimate block chains which comply
with whatever regulation and dark market
blockchain but they will exist and you
cannot stop the registry in the same way
as the darkness about Jamie's point
about when blockchain technology might
clash with what democratically elected
governments are seeking to do like GDP
are like the right to be forgotten what
about when there's a conflict between
those two things the question of
governments and I think the Dow is
actually a very good example to this
possibility it went to the problem and
to the opportunities that are that exist
in the sense that the Dow has shown that
if you have above if you have a flow in
the code then obviously then everything
will be executed as planned and the for
someone can actually take the money away
from there from the Dow at the same time
what it has shown is that it's actually
not as immutable as many people claim to
be because indeed with a particular
coordinated action then the Italian
community has modified the internal
protocol of the Italian blockchain in
order to actually recover those funds
and actually put them in a contract that
people can recover the funds and so but
the interesting thing here and again I
think this is a very fascinating topic
that we need to explore him the coming
years is that the DTO foundation and
actually the decision was not made by
detail and fun - it was made by DTM
community-at-large
took this coordinated action because
they thought it was fair they thought it
was a good choice for internal and
external reason to actually recover
those funds but you cannot impose it
right so at the same time when they
actually decided to modify the protocol
in order to recover the stands there is
a group of people that said actually we
don't agree with that we are not going
to comply with the majority and we're
going to keep the old model and so now
you have two networks one that did not
recover the funds and one that actually
ultimately the way will develop well I
said we are sort of legitimate
legitimate would use that inverted
commas illegitimate blockchain community
and there will be as there is with all
things they're sort of amount more
anarchic fraternity and also a darknet
criminal faction according to the
different views and I think one
interesting thing is that there is like
just - you can look at two different
visions of ideology as you want to call
them you have the vision that is not
about like the imitability the code is
law which is actually quite well
promoted and advocated by the Bitcoin
community in which the code is the code
and the one can actually touch it and
then you have another vision which is
actually more about distributed
consensus right so what is the core
characteristic of a blockchain either is
the imitability of it the distributed
consensus and according to the vision of
distributed consensus then you can
actually quite well imagine entities
what happened when titanium in which if
there is a consensus within the world
community that this transaction was
actually not a legitimate one then it is
okay to actually intervene and actually
recover affinity at the top that has
been done to a particular party of the
society as a world fit can you ask the
dancer the two main challenges home to
criminals and not it's not actually
decentralized a12 if you look at what's
happened to Bitcoin it's it's run by
three platforms and actually all all
things that are supposedly decentralized
in the end end up
centralized well of course bitcoin is
used by different types of people but
but it's also honest to say that most
like I think that the research was like
97% 98% is used by legitimate businesses
to conduct legitimate so it's a little
bit of fuss around the fact that it's
only used by criminals actually say we
pick us overseas us u.s. dollar is
probably used much by much more
criminals
bitcoin is right by I probably three
magnitudes by now so that's one of the
things and the other was centralization
sensation of decentralization only ever
exists until something becomes powerful
and then it becomes centralized because
in the end there becomes an operating
force which which becomes centralized
yeah well you see that the developers
are really fighting this back in a way
they are offering all these types of
different cryptocurrencies which is
harder to centralize so we cannot
develop a single machine that can mine
it and you can also see that even though
the players and the mining is getting
centralized there is a great incentive
to actually keep Bitcoin immutable the
incentive to keep it as it is and don't
steal even if your biggest miner don't
steal from the network from some
particle addresses because of course you
would damage the the thing that you are
working for is there so I don't think
it's a big problem there was a huge
debate between the fork when the Bitcoin
cash fort and and to address the the
scalability of Bitcoin and there are
people that didn't agree with it it's
also quite centralized but now both
block chains are doing fine by the way I
just wanted to mention one thing then
when aetherium fork the interesting
thing was that actually the people that
didn't want to fork it that didn't want
to go and take the money from the person
that stole those funds you know they
were the legitimate ones because
although at the beginning of that Dow
contract was written that the code is
the law and the hacker didn't change the
law he just used as it was written right
so when you look now in theory 'm the
people that actually kept all it the old
way they were the ones that did it
legally right and the the consensus
actually to take money back was against
the law that was set which is
interesting
because I mean in in contract law at
least you have like the wording of the
contract which says one thing but it's
actually just a representation of the
intention of the parties and what
actually count what he's being enforced
is always the intention of the parties
so under how many case with paper-based
contract in which you have something
frightened but that is completely not
understandable and if the judge decides
that indeed the parties did not in turn
that way even if it's written on the
contract it's not it's not going to be
on fast because the intention is what
matter so in the case of the Dow the
intention of the party was obviously not
to have the homeowner taken away by an
attacker so of course it has never came
to court so we don't know what the judge
will not say but there is a high
probability that a judge will say that
because the intention of the party did
not reflect the working of the court
therefore the actual real legal contract
that was created was the one that did
not include that feature as Primavera
convinced you that you will need lawyers
in liberland well you already have a
bunch of them but are they the criminals
well we have to deal with its go live
there and maybe you could face them in
paying tax the issue of
is it just a place for criminals to
dance and and do their thing I mean is
there is there a way I mean that is true
as vit says of everything
of currency of the Internet of telephone
of landlines originally for the older
folk in the audience I mean all things
are open to criminals so that's not
that's not a way to tell and the
criminal uses of these technologies I
don't think is them is really the main
problem is but it is gonna be this
certainly has been and will be picked up
by criminals as early adopters that's
for sure or me already was and will be
in the future we know that there's been
a significant increase in the number of
people that have been victims of Bitcoin
related crime not just saying that
because I was but but and and and and
it's it's having spent an awful lot of
time on the darknet in my book about it
I mean I could see how this is fantastic
technology for those guys that shouldn't
take away from all this legitimate uses
I'm not suggesting that at all but
clearly it means that governments are
going to have to demonstrate that they
are capable of policing some of these
areas properly otherwise they begin to
lose faith in the authorities and they
actually didn't do a bad job on the
darknet with the darknet market so I was
saying in 2013 14 these dark net markets
the authorities are never ever going to
be able to get on top of this impossible
because they used Bitcoin they use all
the various encryption anonymous web
browsers but they've been quite clever
at undermining the markets by basically
writing loads of fake reviews because
the things like Amazon and so people
depend on trustworthy reviews for it to
work so they write loads of fake reviews
they set up a load of fake sites and
then disappear with people's money and
so they've done a good job actually
using other techniques to try to keep on
top of this but I think they might be
losing a bit of a loop they're fighting
a bit of a losing battle and I just want
to say this that it's very important I
know a lot of good people that are
working in this area and they actually
want some regulation they want the
authorities to say you have raised some
money with Bitcoin or with another
cryptocurrency and you've sold it on and
made some money here's some HMRC
guidance about how you should declare
that doesn't seem to be much of that
around people don't actually know what
to do they don't know how to comply with
know your customer regulation they don't
know how to comply with GDP are they
don't know how to run initial coin
offerings which is where a lot of tokens
are issued for new startups in this area
and so governments do have to regulate
but they're not doing much of it at the
moment so I and I want them to do more
and get in this space more actively
because like I said I fear that then
people are going to turn quite
dramatically against all of this
technology they're dealing to too much
breaks it well yeah yeah exactly yes
what about this notion of the code the
code is the law which to some people
would be relatively frightening thing to
say don't democratically elected
governments write the law not coders in
flip-flops sitting around in their
beachfront whatever's in where
yeah it's you're just thinking about the
weather on the I mean basically
California outside yeah though frankly
yeah and its Nevada inside so so the I
think that at the moment the code is the
law line its origins are in the history
of this crypto anarchic world yeah that
was always the grand philosophy in the
90s of a a group of actually incredibly
visionary crypto anarchists who realized
that the modern technology of the day
the burgeoning internet was actually not
at all of liberation as everyone said
they saw that it might actually be at
all of great surveillance and oppression
and they said we need to figure out a
way of making sure governments cannot
control everything and they won't be
able to change code because immutable it
can't be tampered with it's like physics
and so that sort of thread has run all
the way through from the early 90s into
the modern etherium down and other
things but I think it's actually I think
this is the great tension of the day can
laws ever keep up with this technology
our law is going to have to be passed
which are essentially based on what's
technically feasible so if we did pass
if we decided we were going to try to
pass the law to stop big crypto
currencies we couldn't do it so so lore
law and democratic power is or is
already limited to some extent by what
is technically feasible and I think that
is going to continue to be the case
David is blockchain ultimately
undemocratic in the way we understand
democracy I'm not sure that question
quite is a coherent question excellent
rephrase my question so it makes sense I
have no idea what that question could
mean I mean in terms of the notion that
the code is the law that somehow the the
notion that people coming together set
up these systems that are outside the
present regulatory structures which are
there for good democratic reasons right
better the way that well in practice
this is more of stories that fairy tales
the bitcoiners tell themselves say
aren't we an ARCIC the government hates
us the government's not interested in
you they look at this thing and go oh
that's the interesting thing how does it
interact with society that actually
exists so what we see in terms of
regulation is they don't try to stop the
Bitcoin blockchain existing because like
as Primavera said all you need to keep
Bitcoin going is a copy of the code a
copy of the blockchain and two or more
cultists and you've got a Bitcoin going
but some what they do regulate is the
interfaces to the existing society and
economy hence they know your customer
requirements and James right dumb there
needs to be more regulation on this
point and I think that as I said I think
that's the good ending for all of this
is that it becomes reasonably regulated
financial instruments that people
understand but the thing is that's part
of society because the trouble with
anarcho-capitalism is that it isn't
actually actual capitalism it tends to
be people who want to you actually saw
this with PayPal when Peter Thiel
started PayPal he was really gung-ho
about very Bitcoin like dreams he
thought this will be a special channel
for money which governments can't
possibly affect we will but he rapidly
worked out that actually society is
where the customers are society is where
the consuella the people are and there's
a heck of a lot more money to be made in
being part of the system more
conventional capitalism and of course
Thiel eventually became a defense
contractor which is the final stage of
capitalism
but no no I'm gonna come to the or and
stick up your hands because we're very
technology you light here but it's what
it wants one more question before I come
to the audience the environmental issue
the amount of energy it takes to make I
know that mining is a different issue
from the blockchain itself but as these
systems are built
do they not take a huge amount of energy
just to run them where's libel I'm gonna
get is bleeding energy from well by the
way liberland is one of those big places
for mining
even though not locally but I think the
the fourth biggest mine and fifth
biggest mine by our own barley Berlin
there so it's China and then liberland
which is kind of funny but you know I
honestly like we have to start thinking
about you know energy lit in a little
bit different way there is more energy
in this glass then this society on this
planet will consume in next hundred
years you know and the this debate about
and it's this classical Einstein
relativity theory right the debate like
you know are we consuming too much
energy or not it's just like debate you
know are we consuming too much of these
two glasses or not so to me it doesn't
really make sense it's just about us as
a society figuring out how to actually
relieve that energy can you explain that
there's more energy in that glass that
we will use e equals MC squared we gonna
be side by quantum physics well no it's
a thermal nuclear reaction is something
which is very very near the thorium
reactors are also about to starving I
think they just got one up and running
in Netherlands so I like seriously we
don't have any energy and again for me
it's more energy in this glass than we
will ever comes David you put your thumb
down there we go it's like that from the
first day but David you put your thumb
down there is that what about the
environmental cost that will come to
number two there well the trucker with
Bitcoin is that as long as you can get
money for bitcoins all the incentives
are to keep using more and more energy
because mining is competitive
so the actual calculations you could do
them on a 2007 iPhone all the rest of it
is computers trying to guess numbers to
win the next block full of bitcoins like
Computers shouting number Wang at each
other 14:6 Dillion times every ten
minutes with one winner and this what do
we get for this we get a payment system
that isn't very good and we get a sort
of an immutable blockchain well fine and
that's of interest to bitcoiners and the
thing is that it's not that it's at 0.1%
now because you have to ask what
percentage of the world's electricity
would be acceptable like where would the
limit be because there is no limit also
Bitcoin is anti efficient like when it
start when Satoshi Nakamoto started it
in 2009 it was running on his computer
and it ran seven transactions a second
in 2018 it's using 0.1 percent of all
the electricity in the world and it's
running seven transactions a second as
it goes on it gets less efficient so if
you compare it to other things they
always get more efficient thank you
number two a couple of months ago now
focusin came here with his new book the
square and the tower of just about this
concept about networks in particular he
was talking about that there is a
dialectic between networks and
hierarchies a new person finds a network
it's used to great effect and then
immediately some kind of hierarchical
order comes in to stabilize it from what
you're saying Jaime what will be the
hierarchical source to govern this new
sort of network you know we have all
these threats from criminals or from
people who will music legitimately what
will be the outside authority that
governs it Jaime they're number four and
then number three in the back yeah sorry
oh I yeah I guy I agree that is what
tends to happen and I think governments
will regulate it I can't tell you
exactly what that is going to be I've
mentioned before a couple of examples to
do with simple things the way that you
can stop the technology of course
everyone says you can't but is to just
ban its use I mean so to say sorry
bitcoins not allowed in this country
anymore anyone that uses at you and we
can't stop you using it but we can throw
in prison if we find you using it and
they may well yeah or and all countries
like Venezuela saying we're gonna start
our own cryptocurrency and everybody has
to use that one and no one's allowed to
use any others
that's the prospect in ten fifteen
twenty years time that and the way that
I can most likely see this I don't want
that to happen but the most likely way I
can see this being controlled by
hierarchies the craziest system of
insiders and outsiders I think that the
the problem with most existing
production based systems is that they
are so you have a decentralized
structure and you to plug on top of that
at the centralized government structure
hug but the closest thing to a
distribute the governance system that we
know today is actually the market and so
if you look at pretty much every single
deduction based system so far they
implement a market-based government
system and but as we have seen in
hundreds of year and as like if you have
a market-based system that is not
protected to some extent like the
competitivity of the market the
disappear and eventually this entropy
tool of centralization because people
are accumulating resources and using
those resources in order to accumulate
more resources so the problem today and
again this goes back to the governance
question as long as we rely on
market-based governments and that's the
case of Bitcoin with the mining power
it's the case of the Dow which was with
like the amount of token that you hold
and so far then of course we will always
unless we create a 90 centralization
system to an external institution that
is trying to protect that market-based
governance is going to always evolve
into a centralized system and the
challenge today and this is what we're
working with Dow stack with Aragon and
things like this is how do we actually
design new mechanism of governance which
are not market-based which are not
plutocratic based but which actually
implement a real distributed governance
system that to some extent there will
always be some kind of dynamics that you
cannot control but that is not
inherently falling into the
centralization how do we get blockchain
to work with people who don't use
blockchain number four as a lawyer I
would of course agree with prima
primavera but she illustrates very good
which is that most of the discussions
we've had tonight will turn out to be
legal questions that need to be resolved
in terms of governance that's a comment
my question for primavera is that you
mentioned earlier on at the danger if
any one entity has more than 50% of the
blockchain could you just explain that a
little bit more
according to like the little example
that I have given so the idea is that
everyone is racing to create
transactions into a block and then they
need to find the right combination in
order to attach it so the basically it's
a probabilistic thing so you never know
who it's going to be but if you have a
lot of hashing problem you have a higher
probability to find the right solution
to attach the block now the problem if
you have more than 50% is that I'm gonna
I'm gonna try and mine a particular
block with a transaction I'm gonna
attach it right now at the same time and
keep mining another and an alternative
discussion of the chain in which I'm
spending the same ten dollars to someone
else right so this one has been
validated because it has been mined and
then it keeps evolving but if I have
more than 50% when I create this piece
of cashel I can go faster and because
the field of the the field of Bitcoin
and most productions that are based on
proof of work is that if there is a
bifurcation everyone will always follow
the longest chain so if here I'm not
touching two Lots then both of them are
equal if not that is one lock here
another lock here and this one has an
auto lock after then everyone will
follow this as being the valued chain
which means that this distant ten
dollars that I have spent here has now
been spent and accepted but at the same
time now they don't exist anymore
because now I shift to this bifurcation
but so the ability of having more than
50% enable you to mine faster than the
rest of the network and therefore being
able to speed up and modify while
bifurcate and create a bifurcation that
is longer than the Courant chain so we
need antitrust we need antitrust yeah
Bitcoin mining rigs tendency to monopoly
number three yes I good evening we've
heard the ground
about the lovely country where the
people who pay the most taxes have the
most say which was interesting we've
also talked a lot about blockchain and
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies what we
haven't talked about is the use of
blockchain technology if you use the
term distributed ledger technology to
increase operational efficiency to
create digital identity to track assets
that there's a lot of things that will
touch people in their daily lives that
they may not see from this discussion
that we've had so far tonight pick the
panel someone from the panel to address
that yeah the rather more sort of not
prosaic but the more ordinary day-to-day
ways that it can help us operate in a
much more efficient way and David that's
not the snake or side of it is it it
turns out that here it is actually this
is something which I spend a lot of time
looking into finding actual use cases
they're sort of few and far between most
use cases are hypothetical now new
technology is fine and interesting but
it's been 9 years and they're sort of
having trouble coming up with actual
production systems that aren't crypto
currencies a proof-of-work blockchain
like a cryptocurrency is hugely wasteful
and it also recent research shows that
basically all of them can be attacked
really easily with 50 percent attack
except for Bitcoin and aetherium because
they're the hugest
for business use business blockchain is
as I said it's only defined as whatever
the IBM salesman happens to be trying to
sell you at that moment there are very
few production systems out there and
most of those don't actually benefit
from the blockchain bit mostly what they
do is they say oh yeah and we tacked on
a blockchain famous examples the World
Food Programme has a great block chain
based refugee cash system which is
fabulously efficient it's a good system
it does good work and it's got a private
theorem instance in the middle with one
user so it's basically an expensive slow
database run by one company they saw
nothing
very prim very quickly we need to get
some questions then number one and then
number four and number two yeah they say
this saying that a private blockchain is
like we are without alcohol which I
think a private blockchain is like beer
with no alcohol which I agree but on the
other hand you have things that are not
private Fluxion that are like conceptual
doctrine and that actually can have the
interesting application within like a
consumption of business entities or
people that trust each other to some
extent but do not want to trust one
single operators and so in some way it's
kind of a continuum when you are like in
the open public
permissionless blockchain it's just that
you really don't want to trust anyone
but if you have a consumption reduction
with about like 100 or 1,000 nodes which
are all validating the transaction then
you know that the collision can actually
be quite difficult in addition to the
fact that every node is actually
identified and so if someone is actually
doing something that is trying to cheat
the system then you can identify where
it comes from and then cut it out of the
construction so then he's like we need
to think of Lockean as a continuum moved
from like the very centralized and
private blockchain with just a few nodes
which perhaps doesn't feel it need a
blockchain at all to the fully
decentralized and a permission level and
then you have like a large quantity of
potential design of blushin with a
different kind of number of nodes
depending on the amount of trust of
trust lessness that you want what does
it take or what should it take for an
ordinary citizen to be able to trust a
computer protocol now premia various
imaging props of padlocks and the stock
imagery of server racks is very
attractive but at the end of day
eventually you have to take someone's
word for it is that right what level of
proof should an ordinary citizen require
before they say yes I understand that
blockchain works as you say it does this
this is actually a major problem this is
one of the big security problems in
blockchain stuff in practical life
you'll have them saying you have promise
that you have researched all this
computer code and you understand how it
works and like you have well I see a
token sale that they're agreements
say this do you understand this contract
fully even the people who wrote the Dow
didn't understand it fully as it turned
out so difficult to do yeah and in
civilization runs on division of labor
okay
is there a way of the Public Trustee
blockchain that's in the end what has to
happen the probably need to trust and
that the system they are being asked to
join works I don't think the key is the
diversification is and everything so
liberland for example from day one we
had eighty percent of our money stored
in different cryptocurrencies and we
started to diversify them of course
there can be a big problem in etherium
or in u.s. or in other and maybe the
currency might go to zero from one day
to another it's a possibility so far we
didn't have a big problem like this but
I think one of one of the days something
will erupt but for example Bitcoin has
proven itself a great piece of code
which was not hacked in now how many
years nine years nine years without any
major flaw which is pretty a very big
difference that you can actually look at
the code and you like someone like it's
kind of the open source model you know
that someone can look at it and then if
you trust that's enough eyes are on this
thing the difference with the existing
system is that I think the first problem
is going to be with judges when they're
looking at complicated proofs and some
will say well I definitely owned it
because look at this blockchain case
well no you didn't but and they don't
understand what on earth it is so the
first sort of test cases of this I think
will be in the courts when the judge is
try to work out well why should we trust
a blockchain based system exactly yeah
but I think I can see that we can get
round so that had cases but have you
done cases I mean did our would have
been a wonderful case but it doesn't
happen we did a moot court though and
that was fascinating because we had two
lawyers arguing one counts a particular
of our case about the DA and we had to
judge and the to judge eventually
actually refused to give a verdict
because they just said that they could
not understand anything
yeah what is the vehicles I mean in the
end judges would have to sign up before
hi I work in insurance and I was quite
guess my eyes opened a little bit wider
when vid said that our insurance
industry was gonna be taken over by a
blockchain how do you see this happening
well there is a now tendency and it's
it's actually the same problem that we
are dealing in level of governance as
well as on insurance companies you
basically need to have jurors that
decide if the insurance case is
legitimate or not and whenever we come
up with this situation where we can have
an organization that can legitimately
the inside make this decision if that
insurance claim is legit or not the
whole problem of insurance is solved
because everything that otherwise
insurance company does can be put on on
etherium the only thing you need to have
or an a smart contract the only thing
you need to have is a system of jurors
that will make sure that those claims
are legitimate or not and I can for
example I can imagine it like there is a
mobile application which runs on also
under Sandra's ledger you see all the
people from the insurance company that
are customers and some of them are as
well judges so when whenever you hit a
car somewhere you just click you know I
hit a car or somebody hit me and there
will be the three people that are
closest or two people that are closest
and they come and they actually see what
has happened after you submit them the
evidence if they don't agree with it and
they can make the decision that there is
no more need for any extra big
governmental structures big buildings
and stuff like that can we about to be
insurance that woman the fantastic are
you convinced by that it's the end of
you and I think I still see a
requirement for insurance companies then
they may change a little bit but
ultimately you still need somebody who
knows what they're doing in order to run
the company and to provide the product
all of these things that insurance
company normally does can be easily
turned to a smart contract easily okay
it's gonna take couple of years but like
every single step among the insurance
process creating a bunch of people that
basically insure themselves they put
some money to some fun
this can all be codified and turned into
smart contract and that's why I'm I am
very positive about blockchain taking
over a large portion of the insurance
business in very very numbers a short
time
hi dad - Adam thanks well my question is
this you know wave your hand mate
maybe hello Jamie you just saw talking
about you know do we need to question a
need for an intermediary we'll say the
idea that you know is it is it a good
thing if we're if there's ways for
people not to pay taxes that will makes
a lot of sense when it comes to not to
our relationship with government but
maybe to our relationship with other big
entities like tech companies Facebook
Twitter again like is there a way that
decentralization blockchain can actually
protect us help us own our own data
rather than it being used and owned by
other entities can we control it to your
point about the right to be forgotten
can we save the problem is that there
there are that the problem of big tech
monopolies can to some extent I think be
can be read not necessarily resolved it
can be challenged by the rise of these
technologies and it to that end I'm
quite excited about this the problem is
it then it's going to create a whole
load of other problems in another part
of our system namely tax raising and
governance and do you trust in the
police and so on so yes I accept that to
some extent and that's the positive and
the people in the 90s who were talking
about this those visionary crypto
anarchists they called a lot of what is
happening now they called the early and
they were right about it we didn't
really listen so there are definitely
positive uses but this I mean David's
right about this as well there's a lot
of potential use cases there's all sorts
of imaginary ways that it might be used
in the future and and I'm excited about
those and I know this my study I don't
really want to bring brexit into it this
at 8:29 but when it comes to
international shipping if you can
combine smart contracts with Internet of
Things so you can monitor where things
are moving and have smart contracts that
automatically tax at borders there are
potentially very very useful gains there
but it's gonna take ages you're gonna
have to have an international system of
governance that everyone signs up to
there's cross-border and I can't see
that actually ring to reason a she needs
you watch checkers right now I think
they're meeting now on they member one
throw blockchain and who's that yes the
general here then then yes and the
number three sorry yes David would
London futurists and I think David great
David's a point about a most of these
use cases for blockchain turn out when
you look at them to be very vague or not
to need blockchain at all I think it's
very strong and we've been discussing it
a bit but I'd like to ask what what do
the other panelists think is the best
answer to that what do they think maybe
in four or five years time we'll be
saying thank goodness we've got
blockchain because this has allowed us
to do this and we couldn't have done it
otherwise excellent we'll take a
gentleman then there's a woman up at the
back there yeah number two and the
number three sorry thanks Barack Obama
asked the question do we want everybody
to have a Swiss bank in their pocket and
Jacob Riis mogs dad William Reece mark
wrote a book in 1997 called the
sovereign individual where he predicted
a digital currency would undermine the
power to tax and the power of the state
do you think that that's actually a
possibility that crypto currencies could
undermine the nation-state as we know it
now excellent and um hi I was just
wondering if you if you think that the
sort of potential of blockchain is going
to be sort of ruins before it gets there
the reason I'm asking is if you think
about things like currency
cryptocurrency Bitcoin it's essentially
not a currency anymore it's a commodity
so the people who are you know making
money offer are the bankers who we were
meant to kind of get around by using the
crypto currency in the first place
so if we're thinking about you know
using blockchain to solve that you know
patient records in the NHS do you think
it's gonna be sort of ruined before we
even get there yes so David you need to
answer the first one what would be a
good thing that blockchain could solve
which touches on the earlier gentleman's
question about what are the what are the
legitimate things that blockchain could
help us with
I think the good ending here is the one
that's happening which is not things
that are full decentralized
cryptocurrency style systems but just
having that append-only ledger
which is really cool and it's the data
structure that's good
but the distributing of systems is
something
it loses efficiency and this means in
practice it can't compete that well so
what we'll see is we'll see just the
ledger marketed with brand-name
blockchain and I think that will be the
good ending on the technological side so
Provera what do you think of that what
being what what about a good thing a
straightforward good thing that the
public can understand oh yeah if it
wasn't for blockchain that wouldn't be
happening okay quick it's a dirty
already so what is the currency of all
the token based system which is
basically treating your home magic
Internet money which is the one that we
have been exploring the most until now
the second one is the registry like
using the blockchain not as a
decentralized payment system but rather
as a registry system and then you can
just cool things by executing a
transaction and recording a particular
piece of content on that low chance that
you're moving from this kind of
translate system to proof based system
in which you can constantly check
whether a particular transaction as
abandoned upon provide better
auditability and then the third one and
I think that's the more futuristic but
it's getting there but it's still very
experimental is all the thing that
relates to smart contracts so the
ability of deploying software on a
blockchain in order to in a way that is
not controlled by any single operator
but that is actually executed in a
distributed manner by all the
participants and this is what can create
those kind of new type of cooperative
collaborative economy platforms in which
there is no centralized operator that is
actually dictating the heels of the
platform that is taking out part of the
potential hands that they get but
actually creating a system of the
centralized coordination in which
different people coordinate themselves
mediated who does infrastructure and we
have some example like we have like open
Bazaar which is this kind of like eBay
but without eBay we have like some
mechanism like some decentralized social
network like stimate and
Akashi on so soft and then we have like
the more
difficult one to implement like we have
lasers or arcade city that worth trying
to implement Biba without uber and
obviously we realize that it's very easy
to implement the first two categories
are very easy to implement because one
is just pure month you just need to
calculate whether the account are
actually correct and then make a
transaction the second one is just
registration notarization so that's very
easy the difficulty with this map
contract again it's the government so
once you have a group of individuals
that are all contributing to this
decentralized organization then how do
you make sure that this organization is
being managed is being governed in a way
that actually makes sense that actually
is viable when you don't have this
centralized institution and from it the
reason why those is not contract based
organization are not yet fully fledged
still just experimental is because we
yet have to identify a proper governance
structure to manage the organization fit
very briefly time is against us the
point from the back which is before we
get there the whole of the notion of
block chain has been muddied by crypto
currencies so these other ideas like
patient records like more less
controversial ideas will be lost in this
battle around crypto currencies and
who's making money David he said that
there are some non crooks in the ico
scene there is much less of them in the
traditional kind of central banking or
government scene right we don't realize
how much government says actually abuse
the power to create money maybe it's
getting a little bit less but so much so
many times in history we saw a massive
inflation everybody losing their money
and I think you know no matter what will
be developed after on blockchain like
the money that the fact that there is
complete honesty with our money system
that you can now trade a currency where
there is only 21 million and never more
nobody can I was created is the most
revolutionary thing that we can see on
watching and nobody will be ever is it
crowding out all the other ideas it's
the currency you can and I want to just
say that it is the most it is the the
use case where it makes most sense
actually because it is providing an
alternative to fear
created currencies where just government
decides let's create another ten billion
and everybody is kind of fine with it
and nobody can even influence it now we
do have a viable into alternatives we
don't have to use monopoly money anymore
Jamie just the final question final
point of V evening thank you for your
patience audience you've touched on this
undermining the state by putting the
power of a Swiss bank in everybody's
pocket I mean yeah that that is
something you've discussed in your books
in your work and tonight but that that
is presumably a legitimate criticism of
what is happening in blockchain
development I think it is it was and
that's kind of the idea at the beginning
people are using it for different
reasons now but that was always the
vision and I'm not talking about in the
next year or two I think this is twenty
thirty year struggle and governments are
getting weaker and weaker and it's not
just block changes the whole way that
digital technology works and will
continue to improve so it's not only
having a Swiss bank in your pocket it's
also having the power of an emperor in
your pocket which is what's coming and
so it's tax evasion as I see is actually
the people that are good at tax evasion
are going to get even better at it in
the years ahead it is gonna get harder
and an increasing burden of Taxation
will fall on an already aggrieved middle
class companies are already very good at
trying to avoid paying tax just wait
until they can exist entirely on a on a
blockchain floating in mid-air that's
what they would love to do some of these
big companies and if they can they will
and so this is this is I think a
long-term problem governments are weak
enough already people think they're very
powerful but in democracies I think
they're actually incredibly weak and
they can't get things done and anything
that makes it harder for them to do that
I think is a problem final questions of
the audience before we wrap up
who feels our to listen to these
brilliant people more positive about
blockchain than when they worked in the
water in the door and who feels more
negative the negatives have it sad leave
its president Fitz I'm so sorry but
thank you very much Primavera
David and Jamie thank you audience
[Applause]